E
AND TO ALSO UNDERSTAND VARIOUS
TECHNICAL THINGS AS WELL.
PRETTY STANDARD STUFF.
>> CNN HAS OBTAINED TWO CLIPS
THAT WERE NOT FEATURED IN THE
DOCUMENTARY BUT HAVE BEEN SHARED
WITH THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
THIS IS DONALD TRUMP TALKING
ABOUT TRYING TO OVERTURN THE
RESULTS IN GEORGIA IN AN
INTERVIEW THAT YOU CONDUCTED
WITH HILL ON DECEMBER 7th, 2020.
LET'S ROLL THAT.
>> THEY SHOULD OPEN IT UP,
VERIFY THE SIGNATURES.
WHEN YOU DO, YOU'LL SEE THAT ALL
OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO SIGNED
DIDN'T HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
THEY WERE FORGERIES AND OTHER
THINGS.
AND ALL WE WANT IS THAT.
AND IT'S SIMPLE.
OR A SPECIAL SESSION.
LET THEIR LEGISLATURE MAKE THE
DECISION BECAUSE THEY'RE ALREADY
LARGELY ON OUR SIDE BECAUSE THEY
SEE WHAT HAPPENED IN GEORGIA.
>> NOW, TO BE CLEAR, GEORGIA'S
REPUBLICAN SECRETARY OF STATE,
BRAD RAFFENSPERGER CONFIRMED JOE
BIDEN WAS THE WINNER AFTER THREE
COUNTS OF THE BALLOTS.
YOUR LAWYER PREVIOUSLY CONFIRMED
YOU WERE COOPERATING WITH THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
INVESTIGATION WHICH YOU JUST
MENTIONED.
IS THIS PART OF WHAT THEY WANT
TO KNOW ABOUT?
>> YES.
>> WHAT SPECIFICALLY, JUST ABOUT
TRUMP TRYING TO REACH OUT AND
LOOK AT THE SIGNATURES?
OR IS THERE EVEN MORE -- I MEAN,
WE KNOW HE WAS TELLING
RAFFENSPERGER AND OTHERS TO FIND
VOTES.
>> YES, AND THAT ACTUALLY TOOK
PLACE A MONTH AFTER, ALMOST TO A
DAY, A MONTH AFTER THAT
INTERVIEW.
THAT INTERVIEW TOOK PLACE SORT
OF FOUR DAYS OR SO AFTER HIS
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAD SAID THAT
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER
TO SUPPORT TRUMP'S CLAIMS.
SO HERE IS THE SITTING PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES ALREADY
ABOUT A MONTH AFTER THE ELECTION
IN THE WHITE HOUSE IN THE
DIPLOMATIC RECEPTION ROOM SAYING
WHAT HE THINKS NEEDS TO HAPPEN
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THE RESULT
THAT HE IS TRYING TO GET TO.
>> DO YOU HAVE EVIDENCE THAT HE
KNEW IT WAS A LIE?
>> I MEAN, THIS IS A QUESTION
THAT'S COME UP A LOT.
I THINK THAT DONALD TRUMP HAD
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE SANCTITY
OF THE ELECTION IN THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA BACK IN 2016.
AND I HAVE NO DOUBT BACK THEN
THAT HE ABSOLUTELY KNEW WHAT HE
WAS DOING AND HE KNEW HE WAS
LYING.
MY INTERACTION WITH HIM WAS A
MAN THAT WAS DETACHED FROM
REALITY.
THIS IS SOMEBODY WHO ACTUALLY
BELIEVED IN HIS OWN LIE AND THE
IDEA OF THAT, THAT SURPRISED ME
BECAUSE THE IDEA THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA COULD ACTUALLY
BELIEVE IN SOMETHING SO
IRRATIONAL AND STILL BE THE
PRESIDENT IS TERRIFYING.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, HE'S BELIEVED A
LOT OF IRRATIONAL THINGS BEFORE
THIS ONE, BUT THIS IS THE FIRST
TIME IT'S LED TO VIOLENCE.
>> ABSOLUTELY AND ALSO THE FIRST
TIME I EXPERIENCED IT AS WELL.
AND I THINK ALSO IN THE CONTEXT,
I MEAN, THE PORTRAIT OF GEORGE
WASHINGTON WAS ON THE WALL
LOOKING DOWN AT HIM WHILST
EWE'RE CONDUCTING THIS
INTERVIEW.
>> ARE YOU PARTICIPATING IN ANY
OTHER INVESTIGATIONS INTO ANY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
FAMILY, WE HAVE THE OBVIOUSLY
THE HEARING AND THE COMMITTEE
AND THEN WE HAVE THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY IN FULTON COUNTY.
THERE MIGHT BE OTHER
INVESTIGATIONS I DON'T EVEN KNOW
ABOUT AT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
OR ELSEWHERE.
>> SO FAR, JUST TWO SUBPOENAS.
>> ANOTHER ONE OF THE UNAIRED
CLIPS WE OBTAINED FEATURES ERIC
TRUMP, THE PRESIDENT'S SECOND
SON, ON THE PHONE TALKING ABOUT
HIS FATHER'S CHANCES IN FLORIDA.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> YOU'RE IN A GOOD STATE WITH A
GOOD GOVERNOR AND GREAT
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND WE LOVE
HER.
AND YOU HAVE A GREAT ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND THERE'S GOING TO BE
NO GAMES IN YOUR STATE WHICH IS
NICE.
VERY DIFFERENT THAN SOME OF THEM
OUT THERE.
SO YOU'RE VERY FORTUNATE.
>> WHAT WAS THE CONTEXT AROUND
THAT PHONE CALL?
>> SO WE HAD ACCESS TO A PRIVATE
EVENT.
IT WAS A FUND-RAISING EVENT IN
THE TRUMP HOTEL THAT TOOK PLACE
ABOUT A MONTH OR SO BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
AND SO WE WERE FILMING INSIDE
THERE, ERIC HAD ACTUALLY ALLOWED
US IN, SO WE WERE FILMING WHAT
WAS GOING ON, TRUMP FAMILY WERE
TRYING TO RAISE MONEY, IT SEEMED
THEY WERE RUNNING OUT OF CASH,
SO TAY WERE SORT OF MAKING PHONE
CALLS TO POTENTIAL DONORS AND
TRYING TO RAISE MONEY.
A BIT OF A TENSE SITUATION THAT
DAY.
>> YOU SAY ONE OF YOUR TAKEAWAYS
FROM TIME SPENT WITH THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS HE DOESN'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT DEMOCRACY MEANS.
WHAT HAS HE SAID TO YOU THAT LED
YOU TO DRAW THAT CONCLUSION
OTHER THAN WHAT WE HAVE WINCED
FOR THE LAST YEAR AND A HALF.
>> WHEN PEOPLE HOPEFULLY WATCH
THE SERIES THEY'LL SEE THE TYPES
OF THINGS THAT THE PRESIDENT AT
THE TIME WAS TRYING TO ACHIEVE.
AND HE WAS SAYING THINGS LIKE,
WE NEED TO FIND BRAVE JUDGES.
AND UNDERMINING SORT OF THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM, UNDERMINING THE
SANCTITY OF THE VOTE IS
OBVIOUSLY INCREDIBLY SERIOUS,
AND I DON'T THINK THAT LEADS TO
SOMEONE WHO FULLY UNDERSTANDS
AND APPRECIATES WHAT DEMOCRACY
IS, WHICH ULTIMATELY IS TO
ACCEPT THE RESULT OF THE
ELECTION.
>> OKAY, AND THEN FINALLY, I
WANT TO ASK YOU BECAUSE THE
DOCUSERIES LEANS INTO THE IDEA
THAT ONE OF TRUMP'S THREE OLDEST
KIDS, DON JR., IVANKA, OR ERIC,
IS GOING TO TAKE THE REINS FOR
THEIR FATHER AFTER SPENDING SO
MUCH TIME WITH THE FAMILY, DO
YOU THINK ANY OF THEM ARE UP FOR
IT?
>> I DON'T WANT TO RUIN THE
SERIES FOR EVERYBODY, AND I HOPE
PEOPLE COME TO THEIR OWN
CONCLUSIONS.
THE FILM HAS ITS OWN SUGGESTION
AS TO WHO COULD POTENTIALLY TAKE
OVER FROM DONALD TRUMP, BUT I
MEAN, THEY ALL HAVE THEIR OWN
SORT OF ECCENTRICITIES AND THEY
SHARE PERSONALITIES WITH EACH
OTHER AND THEIR FATHER AS WELL.
I'LL LEAVE IT TO THE AUDIENCE TO
DECIDE WHO IS THE POTENTIAL
SUCCESSOR TO DONALD TRUMP.
>> INTERESTI